pour notre dernière journée avec toute
l'équipe on est parti dans le désert à
tozeur et dès notre arrivée à l'aéroport
il y avait un petit souci puisque
benjamin castaldi s'est fait piéger par
la douane regardez bien là on retrouve
le benjamin castaldi de tf1 qu à
regarder
[Musique]
vous avez des montres jeu juste au
contrôle de routine
monsieur et franck a bien sûr les
bienvenus
et parce que vous avez un passeport
armand est aussi moqué ici et vous
faites quoi dans la vie
les deux animateurs non je connais pas
ça contre l'armée est ce que vous avez
acheté six enfants sont français vous
avez une facture de cette façon est-ce
que je peux prouver si voter
je vais appeler un
en train de coaching
[Musique]
chauffe
je vais aller
ok
je dois donc me montrait respecte les
propos des intervenants
oui
bakchich a fait appeler attends je vais
passer mon expertise et après je
roquet est vraiment là quoi vous allez
voir maman ça oui je sais j'ai joué je
vous laisse couler sa maman ici le
surnombre mais ces messieurs attends
attends des messieurs le prouver
allez messieurs c'est de procédure non
non c'est notre bonheur - comprenez vous
pouvez pas entrer en tunisie avec un
second tracé
non non non messieurs s'il vous plaît je
vois plein de voix n'importe quoi
arrêter pourquoi je suis évidement
d'annoncer une expertise et leur est
maintenant dépassé sa machine
on va espère vivre c'est bon ça
c'est pas bon ça
je m'allonge sur trois trous je ne veux
pas que mon départ n'était pas là entre
alors si vous trouvez que je passais
demande d'amour vous pouvez quitter plus
d'un repas cette montre s'est par avance
jeudi notamment de la logan mais c'est
pas mal à me faire à pied 40 et comme ça
on va voir si avec moi c'est la diane
sétois
l'important c'est ce qui vous voulez le
quitterez pas su ici monsieur autre
monde celui l'expérience y est vous avez
la facture de la mandature est ok ok
merci thank you and you know there ils
disent qu ils m'ont piqué le montant de
ces fossiles meurent en une minute
d'atteinte du vent ou la facture à s'est
pas arrêté là je ne parle pas de me
parler de cette façon aux yeux ébahis
matin il m'a dit mon père on n'a rien
payé messieurs s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît vous faire avec le présent tu
disais tout à l'heure avec grille de
prison plusieurs d'ailleurs avec le
président tunisien m
je m'en fous moi je sais je suis en
train de faire mon travail quoi vous
jours s'allongent les rotules
ok rappelé le président appelait ce que
tu veux ok
vous pouvez faire seppuku les ça c'est
votre montre ça je pas pensé à ces
ballons commença ou ne sais pas non ça
c'est de se dire qu'il nettoie
[Musique]
l'ensemble est vendu maintenant j'ai
terminé mois au sol des saluts nazis
non non non non non non non en temps
vous êtes ce policier assez monsieur
monsieur monsieur monsieur monsieur
monsieur hockey votre chapeau is it
hommage à vous votre chapeau et qu'il y
ait montré votre chapeau c'est quoi le
chèche ce soir au quai et si votre net
aussi ok - trith shirt votre tu sors
jamais jamais jamais jamais m
votre t-shirt ramène la vie votre
t-shirt loose est temps qu j'avais battu
shirt vous ai parlé
j'attends que vous accusez
[Musique]
ça veut dire ça j'ai tout lâché si
aujourd hui un beau coup je trouve
maintenant en prison
ok on va en prison
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
mais là
j'aurais aimé le coup de marc touati
un jour je te laisse te piège ray j'ai
un peu l'habitude soit les caméras
toujours et l'âge au début je les
cherche des caméras je n'ai pas vu donc
je me suis dit [ __ ] ça se trouve ils
vont vraiment piqué ma montre ça me
plaisait pas trop compliquer maman
rajeunissement c'est un grand moment et
bravo comédien
[Applaudissements]